Londyn businessman Felicia Koo Booga in
the capital Kigali
in 1993 one year before the genocide
he's accused of helping to finance
kibou Gers alleged to have funded the
ethnic Hutu militias that killed at
least 800,000 ethnic Tutsis and moderate
Hutus in a hundred days
kibou gur was at large for more than a
quarter the century his arrest in Paris
earlier this month has been welcomed by
genocide survivors like Etienne sans
Amana I see absolutely mine Pathan it's
a major arrests but of course we must
respect the presumption of innocence he
was one of the main figures of the old
wonder and he was wanted on several
charges so it's a huge relief that he's
been caught Booga was indicted by UN
court on genocide charges in 1997 for
decades he evaded investigators in
Africa and Europe before he was finally
caught in France French investigators
surveyed Kapoor cos children online and
discovered that one of them rented an
apartment in this building in the Paris
suburb of Annie I saw sin when police
raided the home they found Kabu GONOW 84
years old it is believed that he was
living here for at least four years with
a false identity
Colonel Eric Amir who led the
investigation during the lockdown our
investigators were working from home so
they had more time to focus on this case
to track phones and locations and we
began to survey one location in an e air
we believed he was in the apartment but
weren't certain until we open the door
we carried out a DNA test to confirm it
with him the Paris Court will decide
whether to hand qu boogity un custody he
could face a tradition to Tanzania to
face trial in an international court
most likely he will be transferred to
the Hague and then transfer to Russia to
face trial but it is still possible that
the validity of the arrest warrant
we'll be challenged and that the court
will accept that arguments it's unclear
how one of the world's most wanted men
was able to evade justice for so long if
kibou gur does face trial it may provide
some answers
it might also shed light on the extent
to which the Rwandan genocide was
planned and offer survivors a sense that
after so many years justice is finally
being served
Natasha Butler al Jazeera Paris